welcome to After Effects we're going to
learn the very Basics by creating that
animation from start to finish we have
three short shots each covering the most
common and fundamental techniques which
will be most useful to you in After
Effects there are about 100 ways to get
the same result so I'll show you the
ways that I think are best to those who
are new to the software in order to get
comfortable in it and if you are new it
is okay to be overwhelmed you don't have
to be confident with everything right
away all of the amazing motion designers
that I've worked with started as someone
who is curious and intimidated by after
effects so if that's you you're already
on the right path this video is the
first lesson from my motion Foundation
course I'm releasing this one on YouTube
as a preview and to teach you as much as
humanly possible within one hour the
additional nine weeks are available at
pinmerit.com you can download this
project file for free to follow along or
to adjust to your own needs now this is
the default view you'll see when you
open after effects now like many other
Adobe apps you can customize it which is
very common and but I like to stick
pretty closely to the default because it
really is a useful layout now there are
lots of panels but don't worry we don't
need all of them we'll be viewing our
work here in the composition window
editing it here in the timeline like you
would in any editing software but with a
few more options managing our files and
assets over here in the project window
and searching for effects and editing
our text over here in these collapsible
panels and also accessing some tools up
here in the toolbar now I think the best
way to learn is by doing so let's start
making our project the first part is
this shot that says welcome first we
need some footage to work with so let's
import it I have a bunch of files here
in an assets folder that we're going to
use today and we have this video file
here called ocean drone so the simplest
way to import that into After Effects is
just to Simply drag and drop it into our
project panel or we can import it by
going to file import file again and
finding it in here
so now this file is in our project
window and if we scroll across we can
see some more information about it it's
frame rate its size just details about
the file we don't really need to worry
about that and if we double click it we
can watch it over here now I've got this
wonderful dream shot from a buddy of
mine James Daly which he let me steal
from one of his videos so do check them
out but to edit this to make our
animation we need to First create a
composition to work in now a composition
is where most of the magic happens in
After Effects it is the equivalent of a
sequence in Premiere and to create a new
one we can just select this button down
here create new composition now we have
our composition settings first is our
composition name and let's name ours
sh01 welcome for shot one welcome we
have a lot of presets here for common
formats you might need for us we'll have
a width of 1920 a height of 1080 which
is full HD a frame rate of 24 frames per
second is great down here we have common
frame rates as well but 24 is a nice
safe one down here the duration will
edit from 10 seconds to be five seconds
and these numbers here mean hour minutes
seconds and frames at all of these
settings we can edit later as well so
let's hit OK and now we have a new
composition and first let's zoom in in
our composition window we can do that by
using this menu down here we can go to
100 and we can also use the scroll wheel
on her Mouse to zoom in and out too okay
now let's grab our footage from up here
in the project panel you'll see our
composition is now added to that panel
as well and let's drag that into our
composition window release it and it is
added down here in the timeline now we
can click and scrub through the footage
and you'll see that we have markers for
one second in one and a half seconds two
seconds
Etc all the way up to five which is the
end of our composition and anywhere you
scrub to you can also see where your
playhead is at over here on the left and
do play it back we hit spacebar and
it'll run through everything we have
here in the timeline now right now it is
playing back in real time but once we
start adding some effects and Graphics
it might take some time to buffer
depending on how intense the effects are
and how fast your computer is you can
change the resolution from here from
Full to Auto or to half to make sure you
can view it faster at real time but for
these animations we can keep it at full
resolution and after effects lets you
know what is ready to play back in real
time indicated by this bright green bar
here at the top of the timeline and that
is called the ram preview so anytime we
make changes to what's in our timeline
this green bar will turn gray for a
second and then fill back up with green
Azure RAM and after effects creates a
preview for us but when this is green
it's ready to play back and in the
timeline we can click and drag any layer
to the left or right and that will
change where this layer starts playing
from so now our footage won't start
playing until one second in so we get a
second of nothing and then our footage
starts and the start of this layer has a
little black triangle in the top left
and that lets us know that this is the
very beginning of the layer but we don't
need to start our layer at the very
beginning we can click the start of it
which brings up these two arrows and
drag it to the right or to the left to
trim where this layer starts so now we
get two seconds of nothing and then our
clip starts but into starting one second
into that clip and to move it around we
just make sure we're clicking inside of
the visible area not where it has been
trimmed let's move this back towards the
start we also have our work area in our
timeline and that is this gray bar with
these blue handles on the right and on
the left and within this area is the
area that will preview on playback at
the moment it is the full length of our
comp we can drag this handle at the
right bring it all the way forward to
let's put it at one second and now if we
play it back it will just Loop this one
second in our play area which is very
useful for when you want to focus on one
area of your edit or animation and you
don't want to watch through your whole
composition we can also zoom in on the
timeline here and we can do that using
the slider and these icons down here
clicking the big amount to zoom in and
the smaller Mountain to zoom out and as
we zoom in closer we can see the markers
on our ruler getting more and more
detailed and we can see it's almost
showing every frame now we have a markup
for two frames four frames six frames
every other frame so you can get really
detailed maybe we can zoom out a little
bit though now let's add some text and
animate it first we select our type tool
from up here in the toolbar and to
create a text box we can just click and
drag anywhere in our composition and
let's just type in the word welcome
now that has created a new layer in our
timeline now the order that your layers
are in in the timeline is important for
visibility we can drag our text layer
with lower footage and now we can no
longer see it because our footage is on
top of it in the layer stack in the
timeline and in the preview in the
composition window as well so let's
bring that back up to the top just by
clicking and dragging and let's adjust
our text to make it the way we want so
let's click on it still with our type
tool selected and highlight everything
we want to edit which in our case is all
of it now to edit the text we want to
open up our character panel over here on
the right and to do that we just click
on it and it opens up and moves the
other panels below it this is handy so
we can close it when we don't need to
see it and it's not too distracting now
I am using the typeface swear display
which is currently available on Adobe
font so if you have an adobe
subscription you should be able to
activate and use this font now the first
thing we want to do is change its color
you might be familiar with the character
panel which is in pretty much every
Adobe app and if not you'll see similar
things in here in the office suite or
any text editor but to change the color
we need to select the fill color over
here we can click on it currently it is
set to this dark blue but we can just
drag this up to the top left to create a
white and hit ok now let's make this
text nice and big and we can do that by
clicking and dragging the font size over
here let's make that really big let's go
all the way up to 450 and that is so big
it's cut off some of our text so if we
just click and drag the outsides of the
bounding box we can adjust that there we
finished editing our text we can
deselect it just by clicking off
somewhere in the timeline now to get
this text in the exact center now we can
do that by selecting that layer and then
opening up our align panel which is over
here on the right we want the layer to
align to the composition which is
already selected so that's excellent and
then these buttons here are lined it to
the left Edge horizontally in the center
to the right to the top to the vertical
Center and to the bottom so we want it
in the vertical Center and the
horizontal center now it's exactly in
the middle now let's animate it and
we're going to do a very basic animation
of it moving down the screen and to do
that we need to animate its position
which we will do with the position
property to access a layers properties
we can toggle them open by hitting this
Arrow here and the property we want is
in the transform properties so let's
open that up as well and the transform
properties are properties that every
layer has the Anchor Point the position
scale rotation and opacity we want to
animate its position and we do that by
changing the value of this property over
time which is very simple to do and we
do that by telling After Effects at the
start of the animation where we want our
text position to be and at the end of
the animation where it should change to
so first let's tell it where to start
now we are only going to animate this
over a second because that is how long
our shot will be so we don't need it to
move much so we'll move our playhead to
the very start of the composition and
let's move our text up currently we
still have our text store selected so
let's select our selection tool which is
Arrow up here and let's just drag it
slightly up the comp and as we're
dragging this if you look down here on
the left you can see the values of the
position changing now to tell After
Effects we want to animate this property
we need to click this stopwatch to the
left here and this will toggle the
ability of the property to change over
time so as we select it and it's now
turned blue and we have this marker over
here on our timeline which is where our
playhead was when we selected that
property now this is a keyframe this is
essentially a marker for artifex to know
at this time the value of this property
is this then if we move our playhead one
second later into our composition and we
move our text layer downwards it creates
another keyframe After Effects now knows
we want our text to start animating up
here and at the end it needs to be down
here and that is going to happen over
one second so if we go back to the start
hit spacebar and watch it
we can see we've got our animation and
if you've just created your first
animation congrats Now using keyframes
like this is the most fundamental skill
in After Effects if you can understand
keyframes that they work by changing
values of a property across time you can
do a lot of Animation in After Effects
almost every motion you see is some
variation of that now if we wanted to
rotate our text we could change its
Rotation by clicking and dragging it
over here but that didn't create a
keyframe and that is because we hadn't
hit the stopwatch next to rotation so
its rotation property is not animated
its rotation stays the same but if we do
hit the stopwatch on rotation now we
have the keyframe and if we go back to
the start of the animation we can try to
straighten this out or angle it the
other way and we can also click inside
any of these properties and type what
angle we'd like as well so let's hit
negative 90. and hit OK so now it is at
a right angle facing up and then
throughout the animation it rotates to
the right and because it's rotation so
big we barely notice its position
animation as well okay but we don't want
to take the animated so let's undo that
so we'll just hit Ctrl z a couple of
times until both of those keyframes
disappear and then let's reset this to
zero degrees as well okay now we want to
create an effect where the footage is
only visible within our text and we want
that to take up the second half of this
first second of the clip so from 12
frames onwards so first let's duplicate
our footage so we're going to select our
footage layer and we can go up to edit
duplicate or we can hit Ctrl or command
D which is the shortcut and when we do
that now we just have two copies of our
ocean Drone footage now we want this
second copy to be on top of our text
layer and let's trim it at the start so
it only becomes visible after frame 12.
so we can't see this layer at the very
start and then when we hit frame 12 and
onwards it is covering up both our text
and our footage layer underneath it now
at 12 frames we also want our bottom
footage layer to stop being visible as
well so let's zoom out a little bit and
we want to trim it and so it stops here
now currently our footage extends way
beyond our five second duration here so
let's select our layer drag it to the
left until we see the end and let's drag
the end forward drag it back until it's
start it's the very start of our
composition and then drag the end of it
here I'll move my playhead to make sure
that lines up we need to drag it Forward
one more frame there so now our first
footage layer is only visible for the
first 12 frames and then this footage is
visible for the next 12. let's Zoom back
in now we just need the second layer of
footage to be visible only in the area
shown by this text and we do that by
using a track matte now a mat
essentially hides part of a layer and we
can do that through this column here
which has track matte now if you can't
see these columns for track Mount
blending mode parent and Link you can
toggle them on or off by hitting these
icons in the bottom left we also have
some extra ones for time codes which we
don't need these are the two I like to
keep visible but if they ever go missing
you can bring them back by hitting these
down here now to use our welcome layer
as a mat all we need to do is Select
this drop down menu and choose our
welcome layer which is layer 2 or we can
grab this pick Whip and drag that over
the layer we want to use and release it
and as soon as we do that we can now see
our footage is only visible where our
welcome text is and as that text
animates we can still see our footage
layer through it but something else has
happened our text is now no longer
visible at the start and that is because
when you set trackmat in After Effects
After Effects automatically hides that
layer it toggles its visibility off and
we can toggle it back on over here on
the left so if we hit this visible icon
it's now visible and you can use this to
turn on or off any layer that you have
on screen so if you can't see your layer
anymore in the composition window you
may have accidentally turned it off so
make sure to check down here first all
right so now we've got a text visible
and then in the second half our footage
over where our text is but in the second
half our background is black and we
don't want that we want it to be the
color of our text in the first half
which is white so second half is a bit
of an inverse of the first half and one
thing to know is that in this case even
though the background appears black it
is actually transparent and if we hit
this checkerboard icon down here toggle
transparency grid we can see that there
is nothing behind this text at the start
we have our full footage and our text
but here we just have the text well the
footage inside the text now in our
timeline we can see that that makes
sense because there is nothing below
this layer the background only appeared
black because it is set as a background
color for this composition so if we go
to com position composition settings we
can see the background color that we had
selected as black and the background
color doesn't render it's not really
there and it's just something for you to
look at so you don't have to look at
these transparency grids because that
can become difficult if you had
something that's all white or all gray
or something very thin it can be hard to
see what's going on so let's actually
create a white background for this and
the easiest way to do that is to create
a new solid so let's go up to layer new
and solid we have our solid settings
let's select a color here
drag it up to White hit OK and we want
to name it not white solid one but
background and hit OK and drag that
below all of our layers on the timeline
and there we have it our first shot is
complete and if you are finding this
video useful hitting that like button
really does help me out a lot and the
channel gets seen so that I can keep
making more of this type of content if
you've got the time to hit it I'd be
ever so grateful alright now on to shot
two where we'll be creating this now I
designed this shot inside illustrator so
let's import this into After Effects but
first let's notice that I've separated a
lot of the elements onto their
individual layers and that is going to
make it much easier to animate alright
let's go over to After Effects and pull
that file and while we're here we might
have also noticed that artifacts has
created a solids folder in our project
panel and if we open that up we can see
our background layer here so as soon as
you create a solid or some other types
of layers After Effects automatically
puts it in a little solids folder up
here but we don't really need to know
about that just know that after effects
is doing this no one is hacked into your
computer and started creating folders so
let's import our illustrator file go up
to file import file navigate to where
it's saved to here it is here and we
want to make sure we import it not as
footage because that will import it
without any layers just as if it was the
jpeg we want to import it as
compositioned retain layer sizes and
create composition we can tick because
we need to create one anyway so let's
just import it like this and as we do
that we see we have a new composition in
our project panel and a folder called
shot 02 2 layers if we're opening that
up we can see all of our layers that we
created in illustrator we can preview
them up here on the top left but let's
close that and open the shot 02
composition and we can open it just by
double clicking and if you double click
welcome it opens that composition as
well and down here we can also see our
options for Shot 2 and shot one now by
default the composition settings are the
same as their most recently created
composition which we did for shadow 1
and that is perfect for us here five
seconds 1080p 24 frames per second now
you might ask why are we using five
second compositions when this shot and a
previous shot are only one second long
and that is because it's actually easier
when you've got more room in the
timeline to work beyond the area that
you're actually animating for and you'll
see why soon and it's also often better
to create a shot slightly longer than
you need it because you can always trim
it down in the edit and you have a
little bit extra buffer as well exactly
like if you were filming a scene with a
camera you always want to get extra
footage because if you need extra in the
edit and you don't have it it can be
hard to work around okay so let's start
animating the scene and we're going to
start animating These Bars here which
we're going to have this blue pink and
yellow color filling up the bar
repeating and looping now let's start
with the Bottom bar which I've labeled
bar bottom down here and for this
particular animation it's going to be
simpler to actually create it from
scratch in After Effects using shape
layers so we can do that by selecting
our rectangle tool from the toolbar up
here and if you also click and hold we
can see all of our other shape tools as
well here which come in handy and we
have the pen tool to the right which we
can also use to create different shapes
but for now we just need a rectangle now
before we start creating our shape let's
actually first deselect this layer which
is already selected we don't need that
and that will just confuse things so
let's click off this layer and now let's
create our shape but first we want to
choose its color so at the moment its
field is this hideous looking brown
color up here so if we click on that we
can choose another color and let's eye
drop this dark blue and hit OK and let's
actually Zoom a little bit into our
composition I'm going to do with that
scroll wheel so we're a little closer to
the shape and if we want to move around
while we zoomed in we can hold A
spacebar on our keyboard and click and
drag to just move about okay now we're
ready to draw our rectangle I want to be
as close as I can to this shape so I'm
going to start at the top left click and
drag and just try to line it up at the
bottom right and release when we're
ready there now that creates a new shape
in our timeline which is called shape
layer one but let's rename that to keep
layer tidy and we can do that by
selecting it and right clicking it and
we always label our layers because it
makes it so much easier to navigate
especially once we start having a lot of
layers and especially especially when
we're working on projects with other
people it may seem like an annoyance in
the short term but it saves you so much
time having a clear and organized
project and you'll be everyone's
favorite person to work with I guarantee
it it is a great habit for anyone at any
level to have so you may as well start
developing that habit as soon as
possible okay we can call this a bar
blue one and then just deselect it now
we also don't really need this bar
bottom layer so we can select that layer
and then delete our backspace on our
keyboard to just get rid of it now let's
animate this layer filling up like a
loading bar and like most things in
After Effects there are many many ways
to accomplish this but an easy way and
one that introduces another key element
of After Effects is to do it with a mask
now mask Works similar to match like we
did in our first shot they hide and
reveal specific areas of a layer but
instead of using another layer to reveal
that with a mask we can just draw what
we want to see directly onto this layer
and we can draw what we want to see with
the rectangle tool which we already have
selected or with the other shape tools
or pen tool so make sure our rectangle
tool is selected but one thing that is
important to change is we need to select
this option up here currently we have
tool create shape selected but we want
to go over and select tool creates mask
because otherwise we're just going to
keep drawing rectangles on this layer
which won't help us at all so if we
click and drag we can see as we do that
the rectangle that we're creating is
revealing our layer our shape is only
visible within the bounds of this mask
that we're drawing and that's
essentially what we want to animate we
want to animate this mask revealing our
shape exactly like that starting at the
left and expanding to reveal the whole
shape so let's finish drawing this mask
by releasing The Click I have on my
mouse we want to line it up at the very
end on the right and release okay now we
just need to animate it and of course
we're going to animate that using
keyframes changing a property over time
and the property we're going to change
is the masks path so down here on the
timeline if we toggle open mask one we
can see here we have a bunch of
properties and mask path is one of them
so one second in is where we want our
shape to be completely filled so let's
click the stopwatch on mask path and
then at the very start of the animation
we need to drag this all the way to the
left now the easiest way to do that is
to get our selection tool and double
click our mask which will add this
bounding box and now we can just drag it
to right Edge all the way to the left
just in front of where our shape starts
there
now we've animated our mask path and we
have an animation wonderful now our
timeline is starting to get a little
crowded we have all these other
properties visible that we don't really
need to see and they're just taking up a
lot of real estate and they will take up
a lot more once we start having more and
more layers so a great shortcut to use
to hide that is you on the keyboard so
we have this layer selected and if we
hit you it is going to hide all of the
properties except the one animated and
if we hit it again it hides those
properties too if you want to hide and
reveal different properties select the
layers you need and toggle hitting you
on the keyboard next we're going to
learn another trick for smoother and
more appealing animation and to do that
we're going to want a before and after
comparison so let's duplicate this layer
if you will remember from before the
shortcut is Ctrl or command D so now
I've got two Bar Blues so let's drag
this one just below it and I'm going to
hold shift on my keyboard so it stays
vertically aligned and I'm also going to
move the second one down below it in the
timeline so it matches its position in
the composition and you on the keyboard
to bring up its keyframes as well okay
so the moment the motion we have on both
of these bars is a linear the bar is
filling up at a constant consistent
speed at every single frame the bar is
filling up the same amount but we can
make this animation a little bit
smoother by adding some easing now
easing is where there is some
acceleration and deceleration the
animation will start slower accelerate
and then slows down as it gets to the
end and we can do that by selecting both
keyframes we'll do that on our top bar
layer and we can select them just by
clicking and dragging and drawing a box
around them
and then if we right click any of them
go to keyframe assistant and easy ease
the shortcut of which is F9 very common
shortcut that is another one useful to
remember and when we do that we'll
notice our keyframes have changed shape
they've now become a sort of hourglass
shape and that means that these
keyframes have easing applied to it so
either coming into this keyframe or
coming out of this keyframe and motion
will accelerate or decelerate so let's
take a look at both animations and we
can see there is a slight difference on
the bottom
it is a linear consistent speed and on
the top it is eased let's hide the top
one for a second and we see straight
linear motion and turn the other one off
and we have a nice slightly eased
animation let's drag the work area down
to one second just so we can Loop that
and the top more ease motion feels a
little more natural and organic a
sprinter or even a car needs to build up
to their top speed and then decelerate
to stop and if we look closely I'm just
going to scrub through very slowly we
can see the start our top layer is
moving very slightly there's only a tiny
amount of animation of it being revealed
but by the time we get to the middle it
is having to speed up and move even
faster than the one below it because it
has to make up time for being so slow at
the start so it pulls ahead of our
linear motioned bar and then as we get
closer to the end it is slowing down and
they will finish at the exact same time
so adding easing doesn't change the time
that it takes to get from one end to the
other it just changes how it speeds up
and slows down within that process it's
a more familiar motion to us and is
generally a bit more pleasing now if you
are animating a robot or something that
is already in motion linear motion is
great but generally a little bit of
eating is nicer okay now we can get rid
of our second bar that we've made down
here so let's just delete that and I
think we can make this motion a little
bit faster as well and we can do that
just by pushing these keyframes closer
together so let's select this keyframe
and just drag it halfway until it's 12
frames in half a second so now it's
doing the same Motion in half the time
so we get emotion twice as fast okay now
let's add the other colors of this bar
to really bring this animation to life
so let's duplicate this bar with Ctrl or
command D and let's actually do that one
more time so now we have three copies so
for this top one let's change its fill
color to Yellow so I'm going to select
the eyedropper choose yellow the one
below it select the eyedropper and
choose this pink color and if we toggle
them on and off we can see the different
colors they're just stacked on top of
one another and let's rename our layers
from bar blue to bar yellow one and bar
pink one I'm always renaming them let's
change the label color these layers too
at the moment they're blue which is the
default for a shape layer but you can
change what color they appear in the
timeline and we can do that by clicking
this box here on the left and we'll
change this one to fuchsia and the
yellow one to Yellow now it's just a
little more obvious which layer is what
at a glance in our timeline and let's
select both of these layers and hit you
on our keyboard to reveal their
keyframes too because now we are going
to offset their motion and that is just
a bit of a fancy way of saying we're
going to delay the motion of these to
create a bit of a fun effect so let's
drag our pink layer over about six
frames so it is going to start halfway
through our blue bars animation and then
move the yellow one over another
additional six frames from that so our
blue layer is going to start then our
pink layer then our yellow layer let's
expand our work area two we don't need
to be restricted to one second so here
we are we have a bar filling up three
times once with each color but we don't
want them to fill up just once with each
color we want them to do that again and
again so the best way to do that is to
select these layers and duplicate them
so let's select them all I'm going to
select the bottom one hold shift on my
keyboard hit the top one and then hit
Ctrl or command D and that will
duplicate all of these layers now I do
want them all on top so I'm going to
select any of them and just drag them to
the top of the layer stack and then we
can drag them over to the right we can
also hit you on our keyboard to bring up
their keyframes just so we can line them
up a little bit easier and now we have
each one of them filling up the screen
twice now we do want this to happen a
few more times so let's again select all
of these layers hit command or control D
to duplicate drag them up to the top
bring them over to the right to offset
them now we've got a nice few seconds of
this bar filling up and from one really
simple animation just a mask path
animating and a couple of creative
duplicating moving LA's and changing the
color we've got a pretty captivating
little animation here now we still need
to animate our top bar and our timeline
is getting pretty full of these bar
layers luckily we can do something in
After Effects called pre-composing which
essentially puts all of these layers in
their own composition so I'm going to
select all of these colored bar layers
right click any of them and select
pre-compose that prompts me to create a
new composition name and I will call
that bar color and hit OK and now in our
timeline all of those colored layers
have disappeared and we just have this
one sand color layer called bar color
which is in fact a new composition that
we've made we'll find that up here in
the project panel and if we double click
into that we can see it contains all of
our colored layers and only those
colored layers and this is kind of the
equivalent of nesting in Premiere like a
kind of grouping or creating a symbol in
other software now if we head back to
shot O2 we can see the real power of
pre-composing and that is that we can
use this composition again and again and
if we ever needed to make a change to
this composition we can go into it make
a change and that change will be in
effect every instance of that
composition that we've made all right so
we need to use this for this top bar
here so let's duplicate bar color with
command D and we could just click and
drag it to move its position up to the
top and play it back but then we've got
them animating in the same direction and
we don't want that so let's undo that
and I'm actually going to rotate this
composition so it's animating in the
other direction so let's open up its
transform properties and let's increase
its rotation and we'll try to line it up
with the top and if we can't do it
exactly by hand we can click and type
which we know it'll be
180 degrees then hit okay there and we
can also delete our bar top layer as
well from illustrator so let's select
that and delete it and now if we play it
back we've got both bars animating in
opposite directions wonderful all right
now we do need to get this to work as
well as we can for our one second
animation that this shot will be used in
and make this first one second the best
it can be because at the moment the bars
are appearing out of nothing which we
don't really want and then at the end
they're kind of just disappearing or
just showing the last color that we have
copied there filling up the bar which is
yellow so let's grab our work area drag
it to one second and we want our bars to
be already filled up and animating by
this point so very start of our
animation let's select both of our bar
color layers and then just drag these
over to the left until when they start
they've already completely filled the
bar there we are so now it doesn't quite
Loop but that's okay we don't need our
animation to Loop we won't be looping it
it'll just be playing one sandwich
between two scenes so this will be fine
for us but if we do want it loopable all
we need to do is find the frame where it
matches the frame at the very start so
at the very start we have half pink half
blue so the next frame where that
appears we just scrub along is here at
frame 18 and you can see the frame
number over here on the left as well so
if we drag our work area to this 18th
frame and play it back it should Loop
seamlessly wonderful or we can find
where this particular frame appears
again pink on the left blue on the right
which should be here at one second 12
frames or the 36th frame so if we expand
our work area to there
it should loop as well not that we need
it to Loop but it's handy to know as
well alright now we want all of these
elements to zoom in we need them to get
bigger as our imaginary camera moves
closer and the easiest way to do that is
by animating their scale now I know that
our middle rectangle is in the exact
center of our comp so let's start there
now we'll open up its transform
properties again to get to its scale but
instead of toggling down it transform
properties like this we can use a
shortcut and because all of these
properties are used so often in After
Effects they've got some really easy
Shortcuts To Remember s is for scale R
is for rotation p is the position and T
is for opacity or opacity or
transparency if that's easier to
remember I guess Adobe thought that the
shortcut o would be too confusing oh
dear all right so let's animate at scale
hit s to bring that back up and actually
the bar cutter on the top we don't need
any of these properties visible so let's
select that layer and hit U alright now
we're just looking at a middle rectangle
we're just looking at a scale so one
second in is where we want our animation
to finish so let's keyframe it scaled
there at 100 and then at the very start
of this animation let's raise it to 95.
it's only going to be a small scale
animation we don't want to go crazy we
don't need it exploding out of nothing
over one second five percent scale
increase will be more than enough
playback we can see a yellow square is
increasing in size and it's zooming in
now we don't really want to have to do
this for all about layers so what we can
do is use another technique which is
important in life and in animation and
that is parenting so you'll see this
column on the right in our timeline
called parent and Link and with this we
can essentially attach or link one layer
to another or multiple layers to one
layer so let's select all of our other
layers our bar colors and our type I'm
just holding shift and clicking on each
of these and now in Parental link we can
select from the drop down menu and
middle rectangle or like with Matt's
uses pickweb to select her middle
rectangle layer and when we release we
can see they're all linked to layer 4
middle rectangle and now when we play it
back we can see now all of our layers
are zooming in and that is because they
are all attached to they are all linked
to Middle rectangle middle rectangle is
now a parent of those layers so they
inherit its animation that's why it's
called the parent and now anything we do
to this rectangle layer will happen to
the other layers as well if we hit r on
our keyboard to bring up rotation and
rotate our middle rectangle all the
other layers rotate too let's undo that
and even though we have our scale
animation animated on our middle
rectangle we could also scale up our
other layers too we could scale up our
type layer and that can happen
independent of middle rectangle the
children are free to do their own thing
the rectangle is not an overbearing
controlling parent okay there we have it
Shot 2 is complete the one thing we
should do is kind of tie tidy up our
project now it isn't too bad over here
we only have a few Assets in there but
as we go to creating the last shot it is
going to get a little bit Messier so the
best time to organize a project is
before it gets too chaotic and it is
good practice to keep monitoring your
project and making sure it's as tight as
it can be really so the best way to
organize it a bit more is to make some
folders and organize elements into those
so I'm going to create a new folder and
I'm going to call this one zero one
assets and I'm going to create another
one called zero two comps now I like to
add the numbers at the start and that is
just so they list alphabetically in the
order that I want and into the assets
folder I'm going to drag our Drone
footage and our solids and our layers
from shot 02 and into comps I'm going to
put our welcome our Shot 2 and bars
colors as well let's open up that comps
folder and then actually within that
folder I'm going to create a new folder
and call that one zero one precomps and
in that folder I'm going to drag bar
color there that is modernizer and is
nice and organized now this isn't the
only one true way to organize a project
you don't have to use this exact
structure but it is good that you have a
structure it will go much much smoother
than with no structure and I found this
structure really works for me for small
projects and for big projects as well
now this is a natural break to let you
know that I do have a course available
that I've designed to be the resource I
wish I had while starting motion design
teaching the most foundational elements
in depth across a whole bunch of fun
practical projects I'm really proud of
it and it's available on my website
there's a link to that down in the
description anyway back to it on to shot
three where we will be making this a
little more involved for this shot so
get ready and first we will need to
create a new composition so let's hit
the new composition icon and let's call
this shot 03 After Effects all the comp
settings are fine so let's hit OK drag
that into our comps folder and then
we've got a bunch of assets that we need
for this shot so let's drag all of those
in we have the after effects icon so
let's drag that into our assets we have
this paper texture drag that in there
too and then we also have this folder of
lots of photos of hands so let's select
all of those drag them all in and let's
also create a new folder for these in
the project as well that we'll call hand
Stills and drag all of our hands into
there now for a quick explanation as to
how I made all of these hand images is I
essentially took eight photos of my hand
in different stages of opening up I took
them into Photoshop removed the
background from each one of them with a
magic wand tool and then just save them
out as transparent pngs alright now
let's get started by dragging these
hands into our comp now I'm going to
select them all but I'm going to first
click on hand number 8 hold shift and
then click up to hand number one and
that is because when we drag them in it
will drag them in the correct order with
the open hand at the top with hand 08 at
the very top so the first layer you
select will appear at the very top it's
not that important you can always
rearrange the them but why not do it the
right way first they're all looking
maybe a bit too big for the composition
so let's scale them all down so while
they're all selected I'll hit s on the
keyboard and then scale them down to
about to eighty percent there that's
looking a bit better and let's make sure
we are aligned to the middle so our line
tab happens to be open again so let's
align the layers to composition we don't
want to align them to one another and
there we are right in the middle okay
now we need to put them into a sequence
so let's actually hide their scale we'll
do that by hitting U and put them into a
sequence first we need to trim them down
to the length of each frame so I'm just
going to drag the very end to the right
and drag them down and I want to make
sure they're about four frames long so
one two three four okay happened to drag
correctly to four frames now what we
need to do is just spread them out so
one starts where the other one finishes
starting at handle one finishing a hand
08 and we're essentially creating a stop
motion animation let's see how that
looks alright that is looking pretty
good got a nice stop motion effect now I
do think we want to make these last four
layers last a little bit longer because
it's not as much movement happening so I
want them to just be a bit slower so
let's select these all and I'm just
going to drag them out another four
frames and then push them out to be in a
sequence again okay there we go so the
hand opens up and then it's a little bit
slower when the hand is open wonderful
now at the moment our hand animation is
lasting two seconds and we do want it to
last more than that so we're just going
to repeat the last four frames so let's
select them all command D to D duplicate
or Ctrl D move them to the top of the
layers deck move them to the right and
then I'm going to select all versions of
that again duplicate drag to the top and
offset those as well even extending
beyond the length of our comp
all right now we have a nice kind of
long looping animation while opening
over the start and then jittering
slightly once they're open now again our
timeline is just full of all these
stills of hands which we don't really
need to animate any more than that so
you guessed it we are going to pre-comp
these to make this comp easier to
navigate so I'm going to select all of
these layers right click pre-compose and
we can call this hand
stop motion hit OK and then move that
comp into our precomps folder now we do
want to have our hand black and white
and have some more contrast so it looks
a bit more like a newsprint or maybe
that it's been photocopied and cut out
of a magazine or something so let's now
apply some effects to it which is
another reason in itself to pre-compet
so we don't have to apply the effects to
every single layer now the effects live
over here on the right and this panel
effects and presets and as soon as we
click on that we can see there are a lot
of effects and these aren't even the
effects these are just groups of similar
effects if we open up the distort
section you can see there is a lot of
distort effects filling up the entire
panel just of distort effects and that
is the reason we have this very handy
search bar on the top of our effects and
presets because it is much easier to
search for the type of effect that you
need rather than going through all of
these one by one now first we need to
make this black and white and again
there are a bunch of effects that we
could use to achieve that now one is
called Hue and saturation so I'm just
going to type in Hue we can see there
are a few effects have the word Hue in
it but color correction Hue and
saturation is the one we want now we can
just double click on this effect because
we already have this layer selected and
it will apply it and we can see it pop
up over here on the left and this is the
effects control panel and you might be
concerned where is the project panel
gone but if we select this Arrow here we
can see project panel is just over here
it is just being hidden in the meantime
while we adjust our effects and we can
click back and forth between these to
choose what we want to see all right so
in our effects Hue and saturation you
might be familiar with this from
Photoshop or from other effect software
and we have a few different properties
we can effect here Master Hue we can
adjust to change the color of our layer
let's undo that Master saturation we can
make it more saturated more colorful or
less saturated more black or white let's
leave ours at minus 100 and lightness is
just how bright or dark it is let's undo
that back at zero now we need to add
some more contrast and we're going to do
that with an effects called curves again
just double clicking on that curves
effect and it will pop up over here in
our effects panel now the curves effect
is a powerful tool that allows you to
adjust the brightness and contrast of
your footage now it works by mapping the
input values to Output values using this
customizable curve here so the x-axis
the horizontal axis is the shadows and
highlights of an image the y-axis is the
brightness so at the moment on the
shadow size the Shadows are not very
bright at all our curves at the very
bottom and on the right the brightness
is at the very top so they're very
bright and we can manipulate this curve
to alter those so we can bring the
Shadows brighter by bringing this curve
up to the left we can make the
highlights darker by bringing this down
we can alter the mid tones by making
them brighter or darker and we want to
do both of those last two and we can do
that by creating an S curve so we make
the mid tones Close to the Shadows
darker and click and drag it up to
create the midtones closer to the
highlights the brighter mid tones a
little bit lighter that's maybe a little
too extreme let's make it around this
shape like an s and this is sometimes
called a contrast curve and this is
looking pretty good to me now we might
need these effects controls so let's go
back to our project panel I find it
comforting to be able to see this and
it's nice organized glory and now let's
add a background layer just like we did
before let's go up to layer and we can't
choose anything these are all grayed out
because this layer is selected so let's
deselect it clicking anywhere else and
then let's go up to layer new solid and
we want to change its color let's make a
bit of a dark gray hit OK and name that
background and hit OK
wonderful drag that below our hand and
now let's add our After Effects icon
that's over here in our assets panel we
can close that folder with hand Stills
we don't need them anymore drag that
over here and of course we're going to
need to scale it down so s on our
keyboard and scale it down until it
looks kind of like the natural size
would be in that hand maybe 33 33 will
be fine and maybe let's scale down our
hand too maybe it's a little bit big so
let's open up the scale of the hand and
drop that down to maybe 90. okay now
it's cutting off the very bottom so we
can just drag that down slightly there
we have it that it looks like a good fit
for the logo in our hand let's actually
select the after effects logo move it up
a little bit more there we are now
animating the logo now we want it to
appear as soon as our hand opens so the
first frame where our hand is open is
here at 12 frames in so we're going to
trim the style of that layer so it
doesn't appear before then and there we
are that kind of looks okay as it is
considering this stop motion Style but
we want to make it a little fancier and
add a bit more motion to this logo or to
the icon I keep saying the logo truly an
icon but maybe both depending how you
look at it alright so I'm happy with the
final position of the icon here so let's
animate a few properties of it getting
to this place so scale is already open
let's animate its scale I'll keyframe
that but also want to add about its
position and rotation so to bring up
rotation and position we can hit R and P
but that only shows one at a time but if
we hold shift and then hit R and we'll
now ask to bring up scale they are all
visible so let's keyframe them all at
this point one second in and then at 12
frames in let's make some changes to
each of these properties so position
let's just drag it down a little bit so
it's going to look like it pops up scale
drag it down a touch two not too much
and rotation let's just rotate it a
little bit to the left counterclockwise
so now when we play it well it looks a
bit floaty but it's popping up out of
the end and a bit more of an interesting
way okay so how can we make it a bit
more interesting well we can add some
easing so let's select all of these
keyframes right click keyframe assistant
easy ease now there's a bit more of an
easing that looks a little better but
not too great I think we can improve it
by making it faster I think it's a
little too slow to pop up out here so
let's grab these last keyframes and just
drag them over
to about there so now it's going to be
pretty quick popping up there that's a
little better and I think it's going to
get even better when we add some final
touches which are coming up now to make
this look a little more collagey let's
add some of those border elements and
we'll do that by creating some shape
layers again with the rectangle tool
I'll deselect this layer just to make
sure we don't accidentally create a mask
and a great way to create a rectangle or
any shape that is the exact same size of
your comp is to just simply double click
the tool so if I double click the
rectangle tool we get a shape layer with
a rectangle the exact size of our comp
which is what we want to create a border
but we don't want a solid pink rectangle
we just want the outline so let's change
that the fill and the stroke of the
shape layer are shown up here the feel
is the color it's filled with if we
click on the word fill we have our fill
options and we can choose from no fill
solar color linear gradient radial
gradient we want no fill so let's hit
none hit OK and for stroke we want solid
color stroke then hit ok now this number
right next to the stroke here is the
stroke width in pixels now let's go nice
and big for this one let's go all the
way up to around
250 there and this shape is going to go
behind our hands so let's drag it to the
bottom of the layer stack I'll just
close up its properties here first try
to get below a hand a bit above our
background and of course let's rename
this border one and let's change the
color of this Stroke by selecting that
up here and let's eye dropper the dark
color from the Icon here this dark blue
hit okay there now for the thinner
border let's duplicate this border layer
drag it above our hand in the layer
stack let's reduce its stroke width
let's drag this down to about 100 or so
and then let's change its color from
this blue we'll eye drop the light
lavender color from the Icon then hit OK
all right this is looking a little more
legit now that it has a nice colorful
border on it now we just need to add a
looping texture and some final effects
to make our looping texture we're going
to use this paper scan element that we
have here let's double click on that and
you can see that this is just a piece of
paper that I have painted black and as a
little bit of the paper texture in there
now I have to scanned this in at pretty
high resolution but you don't really
need them to be that high of a
resolution these are very easy to make
your own you can even just take pictures
on a camera and save it out and a decent
file size texture is everywhere out
there you can take photos of some
concrete of an interesting wall fabric
the options are really Limitless okay
let's create a new comp rail looping
texture so again we'll create a new comp
these settings are all great let's just
rename it texture Loop one in case we
want to animate some more textured Loops
later hit OK let's put that in our
precomps folder and in this composition
we'll drag in our paper scan I'm going
to zoom out a bit because we can see
that because of the high resolution scan
this image is very big and a bit bigger
than we need it to so let's scale it
down s on that keyboard let's drag this
down to around 70 just to where we think
the size of the texture is going to look
good what level of detail we want our
texture to have now we're just going to
drag this around to find a nice a nice
group of scratches and Speckles that we
like we don't want to go too close to
the edge and get the Border in there
here seems fine for us great now we need
to make a short sequence just like we
did with our hand so I'm going to drag
again the end of this layer so that it
is only four frames long let's see how
good I did again four frames exactly I'm
good at this now you could make this
much faster by making these layers two
frames long or six frame long or I think
four frames long for each instance of
the texture is this sweet spot for me
okay then we're going to duplicate this
Ctrl or command D drag this layer over
and on this one let's zoom out again and
we're just going to find another area of
this scan texture we can go back and
forth just to check that they look
pretty different not try like this part
in the left corner here so I'll drag it
down all right they look different
enough now let's do it again I'll
duplicate it once more drag it over and
this time to give me some more options
I'm going to bring up its rotation and
rotate it 90 degrees so now we have a
lot more options so we can try different
areas before we notice similar Speckles
on landmarks repeating duplicate it once
more and on the fourth version let's
just move it around over here let's just
go through all of those and check that
they all look decent they all look
pretty good to me let's drag the end of
our work area to the end of that layer
and play it back
I'll zoom in that all looks good and
seamless to me now I do think four
layers are enough but if you do want a
longer sequence you can do that and it
will probably be more seamless you can
do that with six layers eight nine
images long whatever you like but four I
think works good for us now at the
moment this is just looping within our
work area here so when we place this in
another comp it will just show this Loop
once so what we need to do is fill up
this entire comp with this sequence now
there are a few ways you can Loop
elements in After Effects but the way I
prefer to do it is the simplest one and
it is to just duplicate these and fill
up the rest of this comp so that's what
we'll do I'll select these all duplicate
with controller command D bring them up
to the top move them to the right select
them all again duplicate up to the top
move them across and I think we should
be able to get away with doing that just
once more there now we've got five
seconds of this looping texture now
let's add it to our shot so in shot 03
After Effects let's just drag texture
Loop one and place it over the top and
well it's covering everything up but we
can change that and we can change that
with its blending mode blending mode is
this column over here and we have
options of which blending mode next to
every layer you'll likely recognize
these from pretty much any image editing
software and these are just ways this
layer can blend with the layers below it
based on its color and contrast now the
one we want is screen and what screen
does is it removes all the darkness from
that image just lets all the white the
lighter areas show through so we can see
the lighter areas of our texture and the
black becomes transparent now this is
lightening the overall color of our
composition so if we turn on and off we
can see that it's making everything
maybe just a bit lighter than we'd like
but we can adjust that with an effect
and the effect we'll use is curves which
we conveniently have up here because it
is the last one we search for so let's
double click it and this time we're just
going to drag down the mid tones to give
it a general darker appearance so the
main areas that show through are the
very lightest Speckles and paper texture
there I think that is looking pretty
good and there is one more thing to add
to this scene and that is some subtle
effects to add on top of the whole comp
now I think the best way to apply
effects to everything in this comp at
the same time is use an adjustment layer
so let's create a new one by going up to
layer new adjustment layer and that
creates a new layer and a timeline let's
rename that to effects now essentially
this is just a blank layer but if we
apply effects to it those effects will
apply to everything underneath now let's
add some subtle noise to this shot so
I'm going to search for noise and you
can see there are lots of types of noise
we can add let's just add plane noise
the one that just says noise and I'm
going to zoom in a bit so we can really
notice the noise and increase the noise
we can see that it's just adding lots of
chaotic noise to our shot we only want
it pretty subtle maybe around eight
percent noise and we can turn an effect
on or off up here by clicking FX and we
can see that it just adds a little
subtle noise I like the way noise looks
on here you might want your animation
really super clean but I think if we're
going for a stop-motion collage you look
a little bit of noise texture a bit of
chaos just makes the whole thing come
together and often you would get
excessive noise and sort of a printed
photocopied elements too and it just
removes a bit of the digital Sheen that
we aren't getting with this digital
animation all right so we've added our
noise let's add one more effect and that
is going to help make this after effects
icon animation just work a little bit
more consistently with the stop motion
style that we've got for our hand
animation and our looping texture and
that effect is called posterize time
let's search for that post race time
let's double click to add it and I love
this effect and what it does is let you
alter the frame rate of this composition
so it's currently 24 frames per second
which is what it says here but let's
lower it to 12. so it's going to play
back at half the frame rate and I love
using 12 frames per second because it is
a very common frame rate for traditional
animation and it gives your work a
slightly more handmade feel because of
that so let's play it back and we can
only really notice it during that
previously pretty smooth animation of
this of our After Effects icon because
now it's reducing the amount of frames
we're seeing so we're only seeing about
three frames of Animation between these
two points and that's kind of how you
would animate it if you were doing it
stop motion with a lot fewer frames and
I think it works pretty well here we
could even lower this to six frames per
second just to see how that looks and
that's not bad too that actually looks
nice and choppy it maybe fits the style
a little bit better so actually let's
keep it let's keep it at six frames per
second that way it's just a little bit
more noticeable and now this shot is
done the last thing to do is put all of
our shots together and render them out
okay let's go back to our project panel
and we are going to create a new comp
which will contain all of our shots so
let's create a new composition and call
that welcome to After Effects let's hit
OK and now we just need to drag in all
of our shots so we'll drag in welcome
drag n two and we can drag them into the
composition window or into the timeline
doesn't really matter we want to drag
this one over so it starts one second in
so we have a Welcome 2 then drag in
After Effects and have that start right
here two seconds in and now we have
welcome to After Effects excellent now
just like regular layers compositions we
can trim the start and ends too so say
if we thought there was maybe too many
frames of hand at the beginning here we
could find where the maybe the second
image of hand starts and click and drag
to trim the front of that layer then
drag it across so our icon would be
revealed a little bit sooner there we
are I think that works maybe a little
bit better welcome to After Effects yeah
I like the timing for that now we're
ready to render so all we need to do
here is go up to composition add to
render queue and when we do that it
opens up our render queue here and it is
a queue because we can add multiple
compositions to this hit render and it
will render them all in whatever order
we put them in now we just want to
render one composition so no need to add
any more now we have a few options here
we have render settings currently says
best settings we have a little drop down
menu here where we can choose other
settings we click on best settings it
gives us more options now best settings
sounds pretty good it sounds like the
best settings to have and 99 of the time
I render with best settings the only
time I haven't is when I want to render
at a lower resolution and I've only done
that if I was working on a really big
job that was going to take a long time
to render and I needed to send a render
to the client so instead of spending the
last hour of the day rendering I would
only spend the last half an hour of a
day rendering so I'd get more time to
animate and the client normally doesn't
care if they're watching a half
resolution video whilst you're still
working on it best settings for us is
okay so let's hit OK then we have output
module and we have another drop down
menu of some common output and you can
make custom templates for your own here
as well now for most cases I would
recommend outputting a h264 hg64 is the
name of the codec and it is essentially
the best compromise for high quality
with smaller file size the MPS at the
end is the only difference between these
three options that's the bitrate the
higher the bit rate the higher the
quality and the larger the file size for
us we can choose 40 megabytes per second
we probably don't need a bit rate that
high but it's only five second animation
it's not like the file size is going to
be too massive now other options I do
think you should know about is high
quality that is a good one if you aren't
going to upload this directly to
somewhere like YouTube or online if you
are going to be placing it into another
edit which is then going to be rendered
out and compressed you kind of want to
have as few stages of compression as
possible so you can render it out as
high quality lossless will not compress
it at all but your file size will be
absolutely enormous I'm talking
gigabytes for a few seconds so if you're
on the highest quality possible will
choose that and high quality with Alpha
is great if you have any sort of
transparency in your file that you want
to keep if you have any sort of blank
areas that you want footage to be seen
under when you add it to an edit but for
us let's go to hd64 match render
settings 40 megabits per second and then
output 2 it is not yet specified this is
just the output folder so let's select
this I'm going to render it into the
renders folder and I'll keep its common
name welcome to After Effects save it
and then hit render you'll see the bar
fill up
and then we'll get a nice satisfying
chime meaning we're done and if we go to
that folder we can see our animation is
here and we can watch it now we have
learned a lot in this short time about
the most important features in After
Effects and we've only just scratched
the surface of what's possible and a
reminder that you can download all of
the files that we use today in the
project for free in the description and
if you are looking to learn motion
design I do have a course on my website
that is in the description too and I've
got plenty of videos on this channel all
about learning After Effects motion
design Motion Graphics fun animated
stuff
[Music]
all right